Considering the outbreak
of the Peloponnesian War the last thing we were talking about was the alliance
that was made between Athens and Coursera.
And the
significance of the difficult decision.
The Athenians had to make which you will recall was neither to accept the offer
of the course or means of the traditional offensive and defensive alliance nor
too rejected but rather to make a different kind of alliance than any we know of
before in Greek history a purely defensive alliance which I suggest to you
really should be understood less as a military action than as a diplomatic
gesture as a diplomatic signal.
If this is if the Pericles I have in my mind has anything to do with the real
Pericles who existed.
He is.
He is a man who is very sophisticated about the idea of sending diplomatic
signals by action rather than merely by words and that his intention here was to
avoid the unacceptable change in the balance of naval power which would have
occurred if the course Marines had been defeated by the Corinthians.
At the same time is to try to avoid blowing this whole thing up into a major war
against the Pel Phoenicians by preventing the fighting.
In fact I haven't if I said this flat out but let me say it now.
I think he hoped that when the Corinthians approach Coursera and saw Athenian
ships lined up with the core Syrians the currencies would back off.
And there would be no battle.
And the result would be some other way of getting out of this crisis.
As it turned out his hopes were dashed at the Battle of the Boda which took
place in September of 433 to which the Athenians remembered sent ten ships with
three generals one of whom leading one was last dime only as the sun came on who
received orders that were the most difficult kinds of orders you can imagine
giving a naval commander.
His orders were to stay there and if the battle commenced not to engage in that
battle unless and until that moment when it appeared that the Corinthians were
not only going to win but we're going to land on the island of course Sira then
and only then should last a dime odious bring the Athenian ships into combat.
Now how in the world in a naval battle especially where things don't stand still
there either moving around themselves or the sea is moving them around.
How can you be sure what's what's going to happen 10 minutes from now half an
hour from now.
It's impossible to be certain so it would have been a difficult call and I do
think that Pericles anticipated that there might be an engagement which he would
want to regret.
But he could blame less that I'm odious and the generals for doing it.
However that may be
that's all that the Athenians sent.
And again we ought to realize the Athenians had 400 try rings.
They could have sent a couple of hundred which would have guaranteed that if the
Corinthians had fought the Corinthians would have been swept from the sea why
didn't you do that.
It was obvious again that his intention was not to frighten or anger the
Spartans the head of the Peloponnesian league by such a crushing victory but
instead to employ the technique of deterrence.
Now the decision to send only 10 was debatable after those ten had been sent.
The question was raised again in the Athenian assembly but obviously by people
who didn't agree with Pericles approach who insisted that there should be a
larger fleet since and Pericles apparently could not prevent them sending some
more ships.
But the most that could get a vote for was twenty more ships.
So now that there's a second Athenian detachment that is sent some days after
the first which is consists of 20 ships more.
Keep that in mind while the battle which the cities describes in in great detail
works as follows.
The Corinthians do attack
against sea of combined forces of one hundred and twenty is hundred and hundred
and ten course and ships and ten Athenians that are there with their hundred and
fifty and the Corinthians are winning.
And at a critical moment Plaza de Munoz engages the Athenians in the fight.
And so what Pericles hoped to avoid took place.
And the Corinthians would have succeeded in winning the battle and would have
landed on the island and presumably ultimately taken charge of the current
course civilian fleet when something happened that if it wasn't the very stern
and factually determined facilities.
But it was a Hollywood movie you wouldn't believe it.
Namely as all of this is happening you can imagine somebody on one of the
Corinthian ships suddenly looking behind and looking on the horizon and seeing
ships coming and then seeing that they were Athenian ships at which point the
Corinthians panicked pulled back gave up their victory and withdrew from the
fight.
You can't blame the Corinthians once they knew they were Athenian ships they had
every reason to think.
My God.
Maybe there's two hundred Athenian ships coming at us.
And so it turned out of course there were only twenty.
But it was too late.
And so the battle of supporter.
This.
This land.
This naval battle I've described to you ends in this way.
And it leaves things up in the air.
The Corinthians are have not been deterred.
They are determined more than ever to continue the fight.
And on the other hand the course greens aren't backing down either.
And so here we have one of the issues that will be decisive in bringing on the
war.
Over that winter 433 to 432 two events of importance in this connection take
place.
We cannot be sure it's precisely when in that year they took place and we can't
even be sure which of them came first.
I'm in Turgut Turning first to part of Dia.
I'm doing what most scholars do but none of us have any reason to believe it
happened before the next thing.
I'll tell you about City of part of DIA up in the Charles Citic peninsula.
Those three threat three fingers sticking out into the Aegean from race was you
will perhaps recall a Corinthian colony and it was extraordinarily close to
currents.
Remember when I was talking about colonies and the varieties of relations with
the mother city that they had.
I told you that part of DIA had unusually close relations with.
Each year the currency and sent out magistrates who in fact governed part of
DIA.
And this was voluntary on the part of the INS part.
So you have a very special currency and part of the in thing because of what we
have what had happened and what was happening.
The Athenians feared and it turned out rightly feared that the part of the INS
might be planning to rebel against them and to join their currency and friends.
In fact the currency the part of the ins were planning such a thing and in order
to make their chances greater they secretly sent a mission to Sparta in which
they asked the Spartans
just as you may remember the Fijians had done back there and for sixty five.
If we rebelled.
Will you invade Attica and I assume it was the F4 as this is a secret thing it
would not have been discussed in the spartan assembly.
I believe a majority of the Air Force must have said we will.
And so the part of the INS went forward with their rebellion.
The Athenians before the rebellion broke out but suspecting such things as being
in the cards sent a fleet.
There was a fleet of Athenian ships that was going to Macedon don't you.
Anyway for other reasons and they were instructed by the Assembly again I'm sure
it's Pericles calling the shots
to stop by at part of the on the way.
And when they were in part of the ship to take down the defensive walls that the
politicians had on the sea side so that they would be vulnerable to the
Athenians without question which would presumably deter a rebellion.
But when that fleet went out they found that the partisans were already in
rebellion.
They could not.
Get at part of it and the Athenians excuse me subsequently sent a fleet to
blockade the city and sent an army to blockaded on the land side and they were
now at war with Potter DIA the colony of cards to suppress the rebellion.
The Corinthians responded in an interesting complicated way.
A band of I think the number was two thousand.
I think it's two thousand Corinthian hop lights came to part of DIA and help
defend it against the Athenian attackers facilities describes them as privately
sent.
That is to say they were.
He wants to make the point that these were not sent officially as Corinthian
soldiers they were not in the mob.
We've seen these games being played in the modern world too.
They were volunteers just like the 40000 Cuban volunteers that went to Angola in
the 1970s.
Volunteers paid for supplied and ordered there by Castro.
That's the kind of volunteers I think we're in part of the.
At this point why do the Corinthians go through this masquerade this very easily
penetrated masquerade because they knew that the Athenians under the treaty had
every right to suppress a rebellion in their empire but they didn't want it to
happen.
If they had officially sent their own forces to help they would have been guilty
of aggression they would have been guilty of breaking the treaty by interfering
in the other fellows zone and that would have had a very bad effect on what the
Corinthians were clearly deeply concerned about now getting the Spartans to get
the pelican patiently into the war against Athens to achieve the goals that
Karnes wanted.
So that explains that tricky little business so now.
Event number two the Athenians are actually having already fought.
The Corinthians at sea in that battle left Soto we're now engaged in a siege of
city of a city which contained thousands of Corinthian soldiers as well.
And yet nobody had declared war on anybody.
This is all happening technically during peacetime.
The other important event that took place over that winter
had to do with the town of mega.
We've been hearing about that of course at least ever since the first
Peloponnesian War.
What happened here was that at a certain point in that went to the Athenians
passed a decree of the assembly which forbade McGarry NS from trading to be
back.
Let me be very technical from from using the harbour of the pirates far from
being anywhere from using the agora of Athens or for using any of the ports of
the empire.
I'm being extremely technical and careful about this.
If I were not I'd be simply saying that they were being boring the McGarry and
trade from anywhere in the Athenian Empire.
I don't do so because one brilliant late Oxford scholar
came up with a theory about this event in which he tried to say no this was not
a
what he called a.
An embargo.
But it was in fact merely a of an attempt to shame to disgrace the McGarry ends.
It was when they when East when they the the bill says you may not use the agora
of Athens it means the Agora as the civic centre.
This is has nothing to do with trade.
I just want to mention it so that I've done justice.
Nobody has believed that theory
yet and I don't think they should.
It's an embargo and its intention is again.
Well let's.
Why are we doing anything against Megatron.
I think the best explanation is that when the Corinthians had fought the course
marines and two naval battles remember Luke him me and four thirty five
supporter and 433
after the first in the first one a number of Peloponnesian allies and other
allies who had assisted the Corinthians in the battle.
Now at the second battle the number of allies assisting the Corinthians was cut
down significantly.
In my opinion that is because the Spartans had made clear that they wished for
their allies to stay clear of this conflict that they didn't want to be dragged
into a war over it.
And I think the evidence for that is that when you remember that conference that
the course of Athens asked for to meet with the Corinthians and see if they
couldn't work this out the Spartans accompanied them to that conference and
clearly that means they wanted such a conference to take place and they would
have liked a peaceful outcome but the Corinthians wouldn't have any.
And so I think that it was the clear signal that the Spartans gave that we want
you to cool this.
That explains why fewer Peloponnesian allies showed up to help at the second
battle.
But among those few were the McGarry.
Why.
Because we know the McGarry has had a terrific grudge against the Athenians.
Of course throughout all of history.
But more to the point at the end of the first Peloponnesian War when the McGarry
fans had rebelled against the Athenians in their moment of greatest danger and
then had slaughtered as they had a an Athenian garrison at the port.
There was tremendous ill will between the two cities and the McGarry ends were
just going to take a shot at giving the Athenians a hard time.
And so it was important for the Athenians or in any case led by Pericles that
was the way the assembly decided not to allow what the McGarry NS had done to go
unpunished.
Because they wanted to deter other Peloponnesian allies from doing the same.
The next time
Well what could they do.
Well the only thing they're really two things they could do.
Come to think of it before they came up with this idea there was only one they
could march into mega row and fight.
But of course that would be an attack directly on an important ally of Sparta.
It would be a breach of the 30 years peace it would bring about a great
Peloponnesian War.
Pericles didn't want to do that but he didn't want the McGarry ends to get away
scot free.
And so he invented a new thing again.
Yet one more new idea which I again regard as fundamentally a diplomatic device
meant to deter the kind of behavior that was necessary to deter and that was
this decree.
And scholars have fought forever in a day about all aspects of it and most
importantly about what it's for why it's going on what's its purpose.
And unless you understand that as I'm suggesting you should it really is hard to
tell because it could not have done driven.
The McGarry ends.
Excuse me.
How does it help a nation league over to the Athenian side as it did not McGarry
Ns are absolutely determined remain terribly hostile.
Nothing.
No matter how much they suffered couldn't make them change sides.
This was an oligarchic pro Spartan outfit that ran the place and hated the
Athenians terrible Pericles had to know that he wasn't trying to wipe them out
he wasn't trying to take them out of business he was trying to show not so much
them but other Spartan allies that the Athenians could hurt them in ways that
they had not been heard before without going to war and dragging the Spartans in
any commercial Greek state in the Peloponnese and most of them had to do some
kind of commerce and some of the most important ones were right on the seashore
would have had to understand what the significance of this was.
So there we have the McGarry and decree and it is the third of these
provocations as the Corinthians saw that helped to bring on the war.
We would use such terms as the immediate causes the complaints of the the
official complaint says cities would speak of them which are seen or were seen
by contemporaries as being the causes of the war.
And it's important to recognize that the city's whole work or at least certainly
book one is dedicated to correcting what he thinks is an era about these things
in his view.
It's not these particularities that matter it's the true is cause that is the
growing power of Athens and the fear that it engendered among the Spartans.
And that's what that's all about.
Well the Corinthians in reaction to these events Coursera part of the mega press
the Spartans to take action press them to call a meeting at at which point which
would allow the allies to make their complaints to the Spartans and of course
that wouldn't have had any success if there had not been Spartans who themselves
had decided that war against Athens was desirable and were prepared they would
they they would have had to be influential Spartans who thought that members of
the galaxy up is possibly kings we know at least one Spartan king was not in
favor of it in fact and the other Spartan king was in exile.
So this could not have been led by kings but rather by the other two groups of
people.
But it's also clear that the majority of Spartans were not convinced because
they would not have needed to do what they did.
If that had been true they called a meeting of the Spartan assembly to which
they invited all states that had any grievance against the Athenians and of
course you can see that the magistrates clearly wanted to stir the people to
war.
But they were not capable of delivering a majority.
And so the assembly takes place
and I hope you read that section very very carefully the Corinthians make the
decisive speech.
The essence of it is some of it is just sophistry but some of it is to make the
case let's not worry about all these technicalities.
Well well they might not worry about those technicalities.
None of those technicalities amounted to a breach of the 30 years peace they
were asking the Spartans to violate their oaths by launching a war that violated
their previous commitments and the late Ed later in the war the Spartans
themselves admitted that they were troubled by the fact that they had been
guilty of such a breach.
So what the Corinthians was were asking was very very difficult and it meant and
because they so they went whenever they talked about the particularities they
wanted to get past them as fast as they could because they didn't work for them.
Instead they brought in a larger issue that was much harder to defeat.
It was a statement about the Athenian character the kind of people that the
Athenians were sort of all tied up in a phrase that the Corinthians use
something like the Athenians were born neither to live themselves in peace nor
to allow their neighbors to live in peace.
He painted a ha.
They painted a horrible picture.
Of a people who of a state which was insatiable so ambitious that it would
always be a menace to all its neighbors no sense worrying about the details at
any particular moment.
They were growing stronger and stronger and stronger.
It was only a matter of time until they fell upon their neighbors and destroyed
their freedom
Athenians sent ambassadors to Sparta.
They had not been invited.
They were there says facilities mysteriously on other business.
I always wonder what other business could they have had with a negotiating a
grain treaty.
Was it in exchange for violinists and piano players.
I mean what in the world.
I I don't know because of course I think that was a cover story.
They were there with instructions.
The instructions were go to that meeting.
Listen if you think that it's important to do so I want you to make the
following set of statements to the Spartans.
And so we have a speech delivered by the Athenians.
After all the other allies had complained about this that and the other thing.
And
the.
Essence of the Athenian speech I think was first of all they did what they could
to make a case for themselves.
But.
The heart and soul of what they said was this came sort of at the end of their
speech which was
don't imagine that if you go to war against us this is going to be an easy war
for you.
In effect they were suggesting what was true.
We are a different kind of a state currency and say we are a different kind of
state in one sense but we're telling you a different kind of state in another
sense.
We don't need to do what your defeated opponents regularly have to do that is to
try to get out and fight you in a pop like battle.
Because of our Navy our walls our money our empire we don't need to fight you on
the land at all.
And we own the sea.
You cannot hurt us so you'll be damn fools to take us on.
Don't think you're going to win this war or that it's going to be quick and
easy.
That part of the speech was meant to deter the Spartans.
It is confused scholars who like so many people think that if you want to avoid
war what you need to do is to be very nice to the other fellow.
There is no guarantee of that one way or the other but to the other side of the
Athenian argument is very important too.
They said on the other hand whatever grievances you or your allies have against
us and that would have included all of these things I've mentioned to you we are
prepared to submit to arbitration as the treaty requires
in effect if you want to keep your oaths you must not attack us.
You must submit all complaints to arbitration.
The Athenians and again I'm sure this was orchestrated entirely by Pericles
hoped that this combination of approaches would get the Spartans to back off and
allow the situation to cool them
the
city's records two speeches made by Spartans at that assembly one by King aka
Demas who was a personal friend of parrot please we learn from other sources and
who clearly from what he says here would not does not want to go to war now.
And I would suggest doesn't want to go to war at any time at all.
And he makes a case against the currency and argument and arguing for delaying
going to war if got one goes to war at all.
And he hoped to put the matter off for several years that he had to do I think
because he recognized that the speech of the Corinthians had changed the mood in
Sparta and he thought that if the Spartans simply voted for on on the question
of war now they would vote for it.
So he couldn't just say let's not go to war.
He felt all he could say was this is not the time.
Let's wait several years.
We need money we need to calculate all that kind of stuff.
And so that was the argument that he made.
And he said he backed up the Athenian argument essentially saying this is not
going to be a quick easy war of the kind we're accustomed to.
If you go to war now and this is another memorable phrase it implied you will
leave this war to your sons.
That means you saying this is going to take a generation to fight.
That was his argument.
Then on comes the the F war.
Who is the president of the meeting on that day.
His name is Sinclair DAs and he gives a wonderfully short Spartan laconic
speech.
He says I've heard a lot of long speeches most of which I don't understand.
I'm just a simple Spartan is what he is complying unlike these con men unlike
the Sophist that you've been listening to what I know is these guys are now
laying hands on our allies.
And he was talking mainly about the McGarry and the creek.
And so the only question is are we going to let them do that or not.
And I say let's not.
And then he called for the vote.
And interesting thing happens there too.
After you know have the Spartans vote.
They bang on their shields and they yell.
You know so those in favor those who believe the Athenians have broken the
treaty.
That's the way the thing was put to them indicate in the usual way and noble
and.
Those who think not.
Same noise.
And then he said I really couldn't tell which side was the louder.
So let's have a division and count which was unusual very unusual in the spartan
assembly at which time he found a very large majority in favor of the war.
You know I've gone on both ways on the question of what did he hear and why
didn't he hear the first time and so I still don't know for sure what happened I
mean one interpretation is he really couldn't tell it was very close.
Well why wasn't it close on the division.
Because in a place like Sparta you don't want to show yourself as being against
war when other guys are in favor of it.
That's not what brave men and Spartans do even though you'd think that would be
a good idea.
The other possibility is he knew right away there was a majority and a clear
majority for war.
But he wanted everybody else to see how big that majority was.
I don't know what I think.
I think I wrote in one book one thing in another book another thing
um.
And so the Spartans voted that the Athenians had broken the peace and the
implication was we should go to war.
That took place at a meeting in Sparta probably in July of 432 but the war
doesn't start or let me back up the Spartans don't go marching into Attica to
fight the Athenians until probably March of 431.
Why did it take so long for the Spartans to fulfill what they had just voted
for.
There is no really good reason why they couldn't begin immediately.
Some scholars point out in July is too late to cut down the grain in Athens
which would already have been harvested and put away fine.
But that's not all the Spartans have to do in Athens is one of the things they
do is to go out into the farms burn farm houses destroy as many olive trees as
they can cut down as many grape vines as they can.
All of that can be done in July and August and September just as well as it can
be done at any other time.
So I don't think that's a good reason.
I think what happened was that the heat that had been stoked up by the
Corinthian argument and those of their allies.
We only have the Corinthians speech but you can bet the McGarry ends in the pot
of beans and the late on a pretty hot set of complaints as well so did the
island of vagina.
So
it was in the heat of anger that the Spartans voted.
It must be I think that when they had a chance to think it over they thought
that maybe our academics knew what he was talking about and they'd better think
again.
So there is time in this stretch of what is about nine months for the
negotiations that did indeed follow missions were sent from Sparta to Athens to
try.
Well we shall see to try to do what.
They of the first mission
sent to Athens made the demand that there need be no war.
If the Athenians would simply drive out the curse.
Well we know what that is.
The curse of the alchemy on the day.
Well what out.
Me on the day we talking about parrot please.
Mother is about me and if he's the only prominent alchemy in and around this is
an attempt to.
You could think it to get Pericles out of there.
You guys don't want war.
Just get rid of Pericles.
Well they knew the Athenians weren't going to do that.
The idea we are engaged here in psychological warfare to undermine Pericles who
they see rightly as the driving force behind the Athenian policies and they want
to make his political situation more uncomfortable and causing trouble.
The Athenians basically say take a walk and that's the first mission.
Next the Spartans send a mission which in my view.
So the first one as I say was not a serious effort at avoiding the war but the
second one in my view was this second mission said to the Athenians we want you
to withdraw your troops from part of the.
We want you to leave a giant autonomous as you're supposed to.
And we want you to withdraw the McGarry and decree.
In fact.
If you will only withdraw the McGarry and decree there will be no more
that really change the situation because now in Athens the issue could be boiled
down by the opponents of the war and facilities lets us see that there was
strong opposition to going to war on the part of some that why in the world are
we going to war about this embargo.
We have laid on the McGarry ends.
Who cares about that.
And so in the good fight the great final debate about this issue what should we
do.
How should we answer the Spartan offer on this occasion.
Many speeches were made for cities tells us but the only one he reports is that
of Pericles and Pericles makes the case as to why it is necessary not to
withdraw the McGarry decree and it is the classic argument against appeasement
out of fear.
If we do withdraw this we will do so only because we were afraid that the
Spartans will attack us and we were afraid to fight them.
Now if we give way on this point.
Why should the Spartans ever.
Do anything but threaten us again when they want something that we don't want to
do.
We will be under their power.
You cannot give way to that kind of a menace and still maintain a free hand or
any level of equality with the potential opponent that I think was the essence
of what he had to say.
Along with reminding the Athenians
how wrong the Spartans were and how inappropriate was their behavior because he
said remember I have.
We have offered to submit every complaint that they have to arbitration.
They refuse to do that.
How can we in all honor and in all sense of security refuse to resist that kind
of behavior.
And he won the day.
The Athenians refused to withdraw the McGarry and decree the the course of war
was clearly set.
But you know even then it was months before the war began and it wasn't the
Spartans who began it.
It all began when the seasons early or late in winter I guess a 431 made a sneak
attack on the big ocean town of Pelletier which was allied to Athens.
Why did they do it.
Either.
Scholars suggest one of two possibilities either because they.
Knew that there was going to be a war and they wanted to gain the strategic
advantage of having mega row which Assad Peltier which is close to the Athenian
border in their control or the flip side could be they were afraid there would
not be a war and they were eager that there should be a war.
We just can't be certain about it.
But what we can't be certain about it was the attack on flotilla led the
platoons to ask the Athenian allies to help them.
The Athenians at the very least had to say they would although in the end.
Add in the fact they did not and that would compel the Spartans to come in and
help their team and allies.
And that is indeed how the war began when in probably March of 431 the Spartan
and Peloponnesian army.
We don't know how big but very much bigger than the Athenian army came marching
into Attica.
And and the war.
I'm sorry I've forgotten one thing.
Before these the attack on plenty yet the Spartans sent one more mission to
Athens in which they said forget everything we've said before.
If you want peace you must free the Greeks.
That was understood to mean you must give up your empire.
The Spartans did not for a minute
expect the Athenians to do that.
This was a way.
This was psychological warfare for what was to follow.
The Martins were to fight the war on the program.
We are the liberators of the Greeks against these.
Imperialistic aggressive Athenians who are destroying everybody's autonomy and
making it impossible for everybody to live comfortably.
We are the liberators and that's what we're doing.
So now we've seen that the Athenians had refused to rescind the decree and the
war had become.
It's worth asking why did the two sides make the decisions they did.
The Spartans refused to arbitrate.
Why.
Because their whole system depended upon the allies of Sparta being able to
count on the Spartans to protect them from a third party when it was necessary.
So if the Spartans said well we we're not going to do that we'll leave it to
some arbitrator to take care of.
They had to worry that the fundamental reason for the league which gave them
their power and their security would disappear and that would be the end of
that.
They also had to worry that if they did not do what the Corinthians and the MCG
Aryans and others wanted them to do.
The Corinthians might leave the league.
That is what the Corinthians threatened them with in their speech.
As a matter of fact which itself might be something that would lead to the
dissolution of the Peloponnesian Shan League which is so crucial to Sparta.
So that all of that was on their minds.
Another reason that the Spartans were not prepared to give way was that they
really didn't believe the majority did not believe what the Athenians said about
how the war would be fought or about what our has said which was to back up the
Athenian claim.
They could say what they want.
But there was no instance in Greek history that ever.
In which one state invaded the land of the other state and the other states
simply let them do what harm they wanted.
No matter what the Athenians might say no matter what.
You might think that the Athenians had the capacity to do that they wouldn't do
that.
And the Spartans could point what happened the last time we invaded Attica 445
the Athenians came out and made a treaty with us steak they conceded they backed
off.
Why would it be otherwise.
This time I think that you must always be aware yourself when you when you're
thinking about outbreaks of wars anywhere that one of the powerful issue is one
of the thing that helps people decide one way or another is their estimate of
how that war will be fought and what the price of that war will be and what the
chances of victory are.
That's always in your mind.
You're much less likely to go to war if you feel very confident you're going to
get smashed
or that the cost of the war will be intolerable.
And so on.
So.
That was another issue there is a real link in other words between the strategy
that the Spartans expected to be able to employ.
And the policy.
That went with it.
Now of course they're their guests.
There's a great guess about how the war would be fought turned out to be wrong
and very costly to them.
What else could they have done.
Well in theory at least they could have called the Currency and bluff and say no
we're going to obey our oaths.
In the previous treaty we're going to submit to arbitration.
Too bad if you don't like it.
What could the Corinthians have done.
Well they might have tried.
To withdraw from the league in their own withdrawal would not have been
critical.
Only if they had been able to bring with them other states.
We can only guess as to how successful they might have been.
Perhaps it's not out of the question that Negara being as upset as they were
would have joined them.
That would have been a real strategic problem because between the two of them
they control the Isthmus and it means the Spartans can't get out of the pool
penises.
So I don't know how much of a choice that really was.
On the other hand I'm sure there must have been Spartans who said say who's in
charge of this league anyway.
The Corinthians are us.
We make the policy they do what we tell them.
We don't get dragged around by them.
But then the question would be well what if what if these things do happen.
So it was as always not an easy call for either side.
After all the Spartans always had to fear the helmets and facilities makes the
point.
I think that it is fear of the helmets that is always at the core of Spartan
fault policy decisions.
Recently scholars have decided to challenge that but I don't think they've been
very successful with that said it is describes the motives that drive the States
to war.
It gives a wonderful try and fear honor and interest and in this case and that's
usually some combination of all of these things.
In this case all of them were engaged but I think fear is legitimately the one
that's prominent.
It's the one that's lucidity puts at the head of the list and you can see why it
might be right.
What about Athens.
Why did the Athenians behave as they did.
You said Pericles and the Athenians followed this moderate policy of deterrence.
They insisted upon the terms of the treaty.
They insisted upon their equality with the Spartans and therefore on arbitration
no dictation no appeasement.
Out of fear McGarry decree was intended as a warning
and I think Pericles relied on the fact that very unusual situation.
Sparta has only one king at this time and that King is aka Seamus who is a
friend of Pericles and who is in favor of peace.
Kings are very influential in Sparta and so Pericles might well have thought
with Arkady Amos on my side.
The Spartans will understand I have no one aggressive attention intentions
against them I don't want to wreck their league I don't want to do anything to
them but they will simply have to arbitrate these problems and they will see
that and he was wrong.
He was confident here too the same issue the question of how to strategy and
policy.
How do they connect with one another.
He believed that his strategy could not fail the Spartans could invade could do
what harm they liked the Athenians would be able to live through whatever they
did without taking casualties.
Simply losing property because they had the empire that they could live off
which would bring them the money they needed to buy everything they wanted and
they had nothing to fear at sea.
So
surely the Spartans after they cooled off would see that they couldn't win and
then why fight because they just couldn't harm the Athenians.
It was a strategy that was totally rational and that's what was wrong with it.
It didn't take account of the irrationality is that govern human beings.
So much of the time it didn't take account of the fact that the Spartans were
both angry and frightened and finally that the Spartans didn't have the
imagination and I mean I don't want to put the Spartans down as particularly
blind in this respect.
Seems to me all Greeks would have had the same doubts didn't have the
imagination to think that anybody would do what Pericles had in mind and even if
it was explained to them they'd say they won't do it because to do so from the
Spartan and Greek perspective would be cowardly and would the Athenians be
willing to be shown up to be such terrible cowards as they would have to be
standing behind their walls watching the Spartans ripping up their homes
destroying their crops and calling them every name in the book of as they
shouted beneath their walls.
They thought not.
And so
Pericles and the Athenians I think went wrong as the Spartans did really in
anticipating what was going to happen.
And finally I would make this point and make it as a general point about the
outbreaks of wars anywhere anytime.
And that is if you are going to use a strategy of deterrence.
You must have available to you a powerful offensive threat.
It's one thing to say as Pericles was in effect saying you can't hurt me so
don't fight.
You have to be able to show the enemy I can hurt you very badly so don't fight.
And Pericles had no intention of employing anything like a very serious
offensive threat.
There were ways he might have been able to do this or that but that was not what
was on his mind.
He he expected that the Spartans would behave fundamentally rationally.
They would calculate their chances of victory they would see they had none and
they would negotiate which means accept arbitration and get out of this fix
in my view.
Neither side wanted war but neither side was ready to yield for the reasons that
I have suggested.
It's not that this was in my view an irrepressible conflict.
I use the terminology of the American Civil War because really that's what
facilities are saying about the palpitation war that it was an irrepressible
conflict.
I think not.
I think mistakes were made mistakes of judgment on both sides that produced the
outcome.
Both sides felt that they could not back down.
And as Lincoln would say of his great war and the war came I don't really think
it was the case of one side deciding let's have a war.
I think it was they both stumbled into it as a consequence of the situation and
their misunderstandings of what was going on.
So
now to turn to the war itself I have long ago concluded that running through the
war at the pace that's available to me in time would be so too superficial to be
anything but silly.
So I won't try to tell you what happened in the war but you have a pretty good
informant there his name is facilities and your textbook can fill the rest of it
in what I'd like to do in the time available to me to talk about the war is to
pursue a couple of topics in some depth to help you understand some aspects of
the war rather than the hopeless effort to describe the war to you so briefly.
So I wanted to talk to you first about the main source that we have for
understanding the war and that the great historian who wrote it through cities
in his history of the war
I'd like to.
I guess if when I when I give this as a separate talk to people I would use the
title facilities the revisionist historian of the Peloponnesian War and let me
just do that for you not just that title ought to raise a number of questions.
Who is this guy.
Who is this Cincinnati's.
Why should we be interested in what he wrote us over twenty four hundred years
ago.
Also what is a revisionist and how can two cities be revisionist when he seems
to have been the first man to write a history of the Peloponnesian War.
What was there for him to revise.
Well facilities was an Athenian aristocrat who came of age at the height of the
greatness of prickly and Athens.
He appears to have been born.
Let us say about 460 B.C. he was not yet 30 when the Great War broke out.
With two interruptions.
That war lasted for twenty seven years and left Greece shattered impoverished
and permanently weakened.
Never again were the Greeks masters of their fate and that war was his subject.
But why should a war among the ancient Greeks interest us today.
One answer lies in facilities definition of his task
and in the skill in which he carried it out he said it may well be that my
history will seem less easy to read and he means here less easy to read than
Herodotus.
With all those mournful funny stories he tells.
Because of the absence in it of a romantic element.
Take that Herodotus.
It will be enough for me however if these words of mine are judged useful for
those who want to understand clearly the events that happened in the past and
which human nature being what it is will at some time or other and in much the
same ways be repeated in the future.
My work is not a piece of writing designed to meet tastes of an immediate public
like Herodotus is who read his history out in public readings.
My work is a possession forever.
That may sound immodest but his expectation obviously was justified.
For his work has lasted and been judged useful to this very day.
Perhaps more influential in our time than any time before.
But what's a revisionist in a sense of course all historians are revisionist for
each tries to make some contribution that changes our understanding of the past
when we use the term revisionist we referred to a writer who tries to change the
reader's mind in a major way to provide a new general interpretation sharply and
thoroughly to change our way of looking at the matter.
The term seems to have been used first.
After the First World War most people who lived in the Allied nations believed
that the Central Powers were responsible for bringing it on and deserved to be
punished for it.
Soon after the war some people began to argue that Germany and Austria when no
more responsible than Russia France and England and perhaps less soon historians
called revisionists argued in support of that position.
Before long the new view captured the minds of educated people in England and
America even some Frenchmen were convinced and the Bolshevik government of
France of Russia did not need convincing of the wickedness of their Charest
regime.
Since then the phenomenon has been common.
A few writers most notably a JP Taylor tried to revise the common opinion that
held Hitler responsible for the second world war.
And had great success for a while later.
The causes of the Cold War and of the American war in Vietnam underwent similar
treatment these attempts to reverse opinion have had great practical importance.
What happened in the past and even more important what we think happened has a
powerful influence on the way we respond to our current problems.
What historians say happened and what they say it means therefore makes a very
great difference.
Let me just remind you about the controversy about the First World War to
illustrate that point.
The Americans and the English in particular came to feel that Germany was
wrongly blamed and therefore unjustly treated by the vast PSI treaty Americans
use this as the main justification for rejecting that treaty and then retreating
into isolation from foreign affairs the English of course couldn't go that far
but their belief that Germany was falsely accused made it easy to permit and to
justify Hitler's violations of the treaty.
Feelings of guilt helped support a policy of disarmament unpreparedness and
appeasement the English poet W.H.
Auden responding to Hitler's invasion of Poland.
In a poem called September 1st 1939 a poem that was subsequently deleted from
collections of his poetry revealed how deeply the idea had penetrated and how
late in spite of everything it lasted.
Here's what he says.
Accurate scholarship can unearth the whole offense from Luther.
Until now that has driven a culture mad find what occurred at Linz what huge
embargo made a psychopathic God eye and the public know what all school children
learn those to whom evil is done do evil in return.
So we are to understand Hitler and Nazi Germany as simply responding to the bad
deal they got at the Battle of ASI.
And that's all there is.
More recent scholarship is shown to most people's satisfaction that the opinions
of contemporaries were more right than the revisionists that the general blamed
for the first world war can be laid at Germany's door and that guilty feelings
were unjustified.
But it's too late.
The Revisionist historians did their work so well and it fits so nicely into the
climate of opinion of the 1920s and 30s that these people capture the minds of a
generation and helped to move them in a direction that they wanted to go.
So what historians write and what teachers teach can really matter
mostly in the negative.
I mean if we teach you anything right you forget it.
But if we get it wrong you remember
the 70s as much as anyone who has ever written believed in the practical
importance of history so we should expect him to be eager to set straight.
Any errors of fact or interpretation that he found
but his revisionist tendencies are clear on a larger scale than detail.
He has the evidence of Homer for instance to show he uses it that it was the
poverty of the Greeks not the bravery of the Trojans that made the siege of Troy
so long.
He also seems to have been the first one to present the view that the
Peloponnesian War was one single conflict that began in 431 ended in 427 not a
series of separate wars
but my question again is what was there to revise the answer I think is the same
as in the modern instances I mentioned they're not yet fully formed or written
opinions of contemporaries in modern times these are very easy to recover.
Some of us still remember them and in any case modern revisionists always
confront and argue against them facilities method is different he argues with no
way.
And he presents the alternative view.
I'm sorry.
He vents no alternative view even to refute it.
There are a couple of exceptions but even then he doesn't mention anybody who
holds the view he's going to refute.
He just puts forward the view.
He gives the reader only the necessary facts and conclusions that he has
distilled from them.
After careful investigation and thought he has been so successful.
That for more than twenty four hundred years few readers have been aware that
any other opinion existed.
But a careful reading of facilities himself.
And of a few other ancient sources shows that there were other opinions in
subsidiaries time and that his history is a powerful and effective polemic
against them.
One interesting dispute involved the causes of and responsibility for the war
which I've been chatting about to the ordinary contemporary.
The war must have seemed the result of a series of incidents beginning about 436
B.C. at epidemics there a civil war brought about the conflict with Coursera the
quarrels threaten the general peace when Athens made an alliance
I'm sorry with Coursera against Bard as currency an ally during the winter.
Potter.
I'm not going to go through that because you know all about it.
The opposition to the war I remind you focused on the McGarry and the Korea as
its cause and held Pericles responsible for both the decree and the war.
In four twenty five.
The comic poet Aristophanes presented a play called accordions the war had by
that time dragged on for six long and painful years.
And his comic hero decaying populace has decided to make a separate peace for
himself.
This so angers the patriotic and bellicose chorus.
That the hero is forced to explain that it was not the Spartans who began the
war.
Here's what D.K.
populist says.
Some vise ridden wretches men have no honor.
False men not even real citizens.
They kept denouncing mega as little coats and if everyone anyone ever saw a
cucumber a hair a suckling pig a clove of garlic or a lump of salt All were
denounced as McGarry in and confiscated.
Then he goes on some drunken Athenians stole McGarry and woman
and in return some McGarry NS stole three prostitutes from the House of SPCA
Pericles mistress next.
The infuriated Pericles I quote again enacted laws which sounded like drinking
songs that make Aryans must leave our land our own market.
I would see our continent then when the big Aryans were slowly starving.
They begged the Spartans to get the law of the three harlots withdrawn.
We refused though they asked us often and from that came the clash of Shield's
now using the evidence of Athenian comedy to understand contemporary politics is
a tricky business.
Just imagine the trouble somebody two thousand years from now would have making
sense of a Jay Leno monologue or a skit from Saturday Night Live.
Aristophanes is clearly having fun by connecting the McGarry and decree which we
know was supported by Pericles with the rape of women which according to Homer
started the Trojan War.
And according to Herodotus was said to have caused the war between the Greeks
and the Persians as well.
Still he does make the McGarry and decree and the Athenian refusal to withdraw
it.
Central to the coming of the war both in accordions and then another company
another comedy he wrote called Peace performed and for twenty one in the latter
play he makes Hermes the God explained to the war weary Athenian farmers how
peace was lost in the first place.
I quote the beginning of our trouble was the disgrace of Phineas.
He's referring to the great sculptor who had been charged with piety in
connection with the great statue of Athena that he had constructed for the
Parthenon then parolees fearing he might share in the misfortune because Phineas
was his close friend dreading your ill nature.
That is the Athenians and your stubborn ways.
Before he could suffer harm.
Set the city aflame with that little spark that McGarry and decree well the full
context reveals that the connection between the attacks on the great sculptor
Phineas Pericles friend and associate and the McGarry and the Cree was
Aristophanes own joke.
But it was taken seriously by other ancient writers and it surely reflected
charges that were made by real contemporary enemies of Pericles the hard Colonel
of opinion central to all this.
Is the common belief that the cause of the war was the McGarry and decree and
that Pericles was responsible for.
Well of course that view at the very most is an oversimplification and any good
historian would have rejected it as a sufficient explanation.
Said it is in fact gives it very little attention.
He doesn't mention it in its natural place in the narrative.
He doesn't give it date.
He doesn't tell us the purpose or he doesn't and he doesn't tell us how it
worked in practice.
He does not conceal the fact.
That the piece was conditional on its withdrawal or that it became the center of
the final debate in Athens his way of refuting the common opinion was to
indicate it's unimportant it by the small place it occupies in his account.
And to included among all the specific quarrels that he regards as insignificant
his own explicit interpretation is a sweeping revision of the usual explanation
and it's the one I've told you about before and he states that same explanation
in other words twice more in his account of the war's origins and the whole
first book is a carefully organized unit meant to support that interpretation
and so skillfully and powerfully did he work that his interpretation has
convinced all but a few readers over the centuries.
I should point out that in spite of my clearing up that error.
It's been available for about 40 years now.
I hate to tell you but most people still agree with facilities and not with me.
The revisionist view quickly and last thing Lee became orthodoxy
another controversy surrounds Paris police most unusual strategy for waging the
war.
And I'll talk to you about that next time.
So let me move on to the next point.
Here we go.
Sorry about this
point I want to make.
In any case the other instance that I want to bring to your attention is in the
summary that subsidies makes of Pericles career and of his importance to Athens
in Chapter 65 of book 2 after Pericles death.
He interrupts the narrative to give this really lengthy evaluation.
One of the things he says in that evaluation is that
Athens in the time of Pericles was a democracy in name but the rule of the first
citizen in fact that is a remarkably powerful statement.
He is saying that
apparently in Athens was not a democracy and that it was
in effect some kind of an autocratic government with Pericles as the autocrat.
I would say that all the evidence we have suggests that that is not accurate.
Just a few points to illustrate why that is so.
I mean you want one way to do that I think is by comparison.
People have suggested what that what some cities are saying is like what
Augustus the Emperor of Rome said about himself that he ruled not by any
particular power not by protest US but by his our torrid task that is to say
that by by the influence that his persona and his achievements and all those
things had over his fellow citizens.
Well in the case of Augustus it was a flat lie.
Augustus had a monopoly of all the armed force there was in the Mediterranean.
He also had a vast treasury that he could use for his own purposes.
He was as all historians in the modern world make perfectly clear.
He was an emperor who ruled it was no matter what instruments he used.
It was a one man rule.
Then the second you can see how it doesn't apply to Pericles Pericles had no
armed forces available to him.
He could not enforce anything by pulling out some soldiers to do anything that
he wanted to do.
Anything.
Any use of any armed forces always had to be voted by the Assembly and debated
and discussed and a majority determined whether it could be done
moreover every month.
The question was raised as you know.
Is parallelism like all the other generals okay or has he violated anything.
Charges could be brought against him.
He could be brought to chuck it to court and that's what happened to him in the
middle of the war and 430 his enemies did bring him did bring charges against
him.
He was convicted he was removed temporarily from the general ship and he had to
pay a very very heavy fine.
This is not the business of dictators so very briefly their citizen is wrong
about that.
Why did he want to say that.
And this gets to my own explanation of how we can understand.
I've made the the argument that he's wrong about the origins of war.
Next time I'll make the case of the war next time I'll make the case that he was
wrong in fully supporting strip Pericles strategy in the Peloponnesian War as
the correct one.
I make the claim that the opposite is true.
If I'm right why in the world did he say the things he did and I think we need
to understand his situation and for 24 he was a general commanding Athenian
force.
Naval forces in the north.
He was.
Away from the place where they expected him to be.
When there was this suddenly surprise seizure of the important Athenian city of
in fifth palace.
A charge was brought against him.
He was brought to trial and he was found guilty and sent into exile.
He spent the last.
20 years of the war in exile.
Probably I would guess among fellow exiles and fellow opponents of the Athenian
democracy because he is very clearly a critic of the Athenian democracy.
And there he had to speak all the time to people who said wait a minute their
city let me get this right.
You think Pericles was a terrific guy don't you.
Yes I do.
He would have had to say to his end.
He said.
And they said besides didn't you get elected general in 424.
And wasn't that about the most radical year in the entire history of Athenian
democracy.
Weren't you a great pal.
How could it be a blue blood like you.
Who knows what nonsense democracy is.
How could you possibly hold those positions.
And my view his history is his answer to those questions you think that the war
is about the McGarry and decree and that Pericles is responsible for it.
You're completely wrong.
The war was inevitable and became so as soon as the Athenian Empire came on
board to challenge the Spartan hegemony.
Your view is naive and ignorant.
So please pay attention to my history when I get it fully written.
You think that Pericles was a Democrat.
You bloody fool he was a man who ruled over others.
He did not take his orders from the assembly.
What's my.
Oh yeah.
You think that we lost the war because we had a bad strategy.
The truth is the strategy was right.
And if his successors had not abandoned that they would have held out and won
the war.
And so you'd see all of your main ideas about what's happened to us in the past
are wrong.
And that is why I did what I did and I was right to do so every step of the way.
That was his history.
In my view was not merely an account of the past.
It was an apple low job pro veto sewer a defense of his own life and of the
great decisions that were made in it.
And of course what I've just said is highly controversial.
Next time we'll talk about the strategy in the war.